it's April of 2007 and John Corzine
the governor of New Jersey is in this
horrific car accident he's in the right
front passenger seat of this SUV when it
crashes on the Garden State Parkway he's
transported to a New Jersey trauma
center with multiple broken bones and
multiple lacerations he needs immediate
surgery seven units of blood a
mechanical ventilator to help him
breathe and several more operations
along the way it's amazing he survived
but perhaps even more amazing he was not
wearing a seat belt and in fact he never
wore a seat belt and the New Jersey
State Troopers who used to drive
governor Corzine around used to beg him
to wear a seat belt but he didn't do it
now before Corzine was governor of New
Jersey he was the US senator from New
Jersey and before that he was the CEO of
Goldman Sachs responsible for taking
Goldman Sachs public making hundreds of
millions of dollars now no matter what
you think of Jon Corzine politically or
how he made his money nobody would say
that he was stupid but there he was an
unrestrained passenger in a car accident
at a time when every American knows that
seatbelts save lives this single story
reflects a fundamental weakness in our
approach to improving health behavior
nearly everything we tell doctors and
everything we tell patients is based on
the idea that we behave rationally if
you give me information I will process
that information in my head and my
behavior will change as a result do you
think Jon Corzine didn't know that
seatbelts save lives do you think he'd
like just didn't get the memo
jon corzine did not have a knowledge
deficit he had a behavior deficit it's
not that he didn't know better he knew
better it's that he didn't do better
instead I think the mind is a
high-resistance pathway changing
someone's mind with information is hard
enough changing their behavior with
information is harder still the only way
we're going to make substantial
improvements in health and health care
is to make substantial improvements in
the behavior of health and health care
if you hit my patellar tendon with a
reflex hammer my leg is going to jerk
forward and it's going to jerk forward a
lot faster and a lot more predictably
than if I had to think about it myself
it's a reflex we need to look for the
equivalent behavioral reflexes and hitch
our health care wagon to those turns out
though that most conventional approaches
to human motivation are based on the
idea of Education we assume that if
people don't behave as they should it's
because they didn't know any better if
only people knew that smoking was
dangerous they wouldn't smoke or we
think about economics the assumption
there is that we're all constantly
calculating the costs and benefits of
every one of our actions and optimizing
that to make the perfectly right
rational decision if that were true then
all we need to do is to find the perfect
payment system for doctors with our
perfect co-payments and deductibles for
patients and everything would work out a
better approach lies in behavioral
economics behavioral economists
recognize that we are irrational our
decisions are based on emotion or
they're sensitive to framing or to
social context we don't always do what's
in our own long-term best interest but
the key contribution of behavioral
economics is not in recognizing that we
are irrational it's recognizing that we
are irrational in highly predictable
ways in fact it's the predictability of
our psychological foibles that allows us
to design strategies to overcome them
forewarned is forearmed
in fact behavioral economists often use
precisely the same behavioral reflexes
that get us into trouble
and turn them around to help us rather
than to hurt us we see irrationality
play out in something called present
bias where the outcomes in front of us
are much more motivating that even more
important outcomes far in the future if
I'm on a diet and I'm always on a diet
and someone offers me a luscious looking
piece of chocolate cake I know I should
not eat that chocolate cake that
chocolate cake will land on that part of
my body permanently where that kind of
food naturally settles but the chocolate
cake looks so good and delicious and
it's right in front of me and the diet
can wait till tomorrow I used to love
the comedian Steven Wright he would have
the zen-like quips and my favorite one
was this hard work pays off in the
future but laziness pays off right now
and patients also have present bias if
you have high blood pressure even if you
would desperately like to avoid a stroke
and you know that taking your
antihypertensive medications is one of
the best ways to reduce that risk the
stroke you avoid is far in the future
and taking medications is right now
almost half of the patients who are
prescribed high blood pressure pills
stop taking them within a year think of
how many lives we could save if we could
solve just that one problem we also tend
to overestimate the value of small
probabilities this actually explains why
state lotteries are so popular even
though they return pennies on the dollar
now some of you may buy lottery tickets
it's fun there's the chances you might
strike it rich but let's face it this
would be a horrible way to invest your
retirement savings I once saw a bumper
sticker I'm not making this up that said
state lotteries are a special tax on
people who can't do math
it's not that we can't do the math it's
that we can't feel the math and we also
pay much too much attention to regret we
all hate the feeling of missing out so
actually there was this recent lottery
that had mega jackpot lottery that had a
huge payoff something like over a
billion dollars and every one of my
office is pooling money to buy lottery
tickets and I'm not having any of this
there I am like swaggering around the
office lotteries or a special tax on
people who can't do math and then it
hits me
Oh what if they win I'm the only one who
shows up at work the next day now it's
not that I didn't want my colleagues to
win I just didn't want them to win
without me now it would have been easier
if I just taken my twenty dollar bill
and put it into the office shredder and
the results would have been the same
even though I knew I shouldn't
participate I handed over my $20 bill
and I never saw it again
we've done a bunch of experiments with
patients in which we give them these
electronic pill bottles so we can tell
whether they're taking their medication
or not and we reward them with a lottery
they get prizes but they only get prizes
if they had taken their medication the
day before if not they get a message
that says something like you would have
won $100 but you didn't take your
medicine yesterday so you don't get it
well it turns out patients hate that
they hate the sense of missing out and
because they can anticipate that feeling
of regret and they'd like to avoid it
they're much more likely to take their
medications harnessing that sense of
hating regret works and it leads to the
more general point which is once you
recognize how people are irrational
you're in a much better position to help
them now this kind of irrationality
works out even in men's restaurants so
for those of you who haven't don't
frequent urinals let me break this down
for you
there is pee all over the floor and it
turns out that you can solve this
problem by etching the image of a fly in
the back of the urinal and it makes and
it makes perfect sense if I see a fly
I'm gonna get that slide that fly is
going down now this naturally begs the
question that if men can aim
why were they peeing on the floor in the
first place in fact if they were gonna
pee on the floor why pee in front of the
urinal you could pee anywhere and the
same thing works in health care we had a
problem in our Hospital in which the
physicians were prescribing brand-name
drugs when a generic drug was available
now each one of the lines on this graph
represents a different drug and they're
listed according to how often they were
prescribed as generic medications those
at the top are prescribed as generics
100% of the time those down at the
bottom are prescribed as generics less
than 20% of the time and we'd have
meetings with clinicians and all sorts
of education sessions and nothing worked
all the lines are pretty much horizontal
until someone installed a little piece
of software in the electronic health
record that defaulted the prescriptions
to generic medications instead of the
brand-name drugs now it doesn't take a
statistician to see that this problem
was solved overnight and it has stayed
solved ever since in fact in the
two-and-a-half years since this program
started our Hospital has saved thirty
two million dollars let me say that
again thirty two million dollars and all
we did was make it easier for the
doctors to do what they fundamentally
wanted to do all along it also works to
play into people's notions of loss we
did this with a contest to help people
walk more we wanted to everyone to walk
at least seven thousand steps and we
measured their step count with the
accelerometer on their cell phone
group a the control group just got told
whether they had walked 7000 steps or
not
Group B got a financial incentive we
gave them a dollar 40 for every day they
walk 7000 steps Group C got the same
financial incentive but it was framed as
a loss rather than a game a dollar 40 a
day is $42 a month so he gave these
participants $42 at the beginning of
each month in a virtual account that
they could see and we took away a dollar
40 for every day they didn't walk 7,000
steps now an economist would say that
those two financial incentives are the
same for every day you walk 7,000 steps
you're a dollar 40 richer but a
behavioral economists would say that
they're different because we're much
more motivated to avoid a dollar 40 loss
than we are motivated to achieve a
dollar 40 gain and that's exactly what
happened those in the group that
received a dollar 40 for every day they
walk 7,000 steps were no more likely to
meet their gold in the control group the
financial incentive didn't work but
those who had a loss framed incentive
met their goal 50% more of the time it
doesn't make economic sense but it makes
psychological sense because losses loom
larger than gains and now we're using
loss framed incentives to help patients
walk more lose weight and take their
medications money can be a motivator we
all know that but it's far more
influential when it's paired with
psychology and money of course has its
own disadvantages my favorite example of
this involves a daycare program the
greatest sin you can commit in daycare
is picking up your kids late no one is
happy right your kids are crying because
you don't love them
the teachers are unhappy because they
leave work late and you feel terribly
guilty this daycare program in Israel
decided they wanted to stop this problem
they did something that many daycare
programs in the US do which is they
installed a fine for late pickups and
the fine they chose was 10 shekels which
is about 3 bucks and guess what happened
late pickups increased and if you think
about it it makes perfect sense what a
deal for ten shekels you can keep my
kids all night they took a perfectly
strong intrinsic motivation not to be
late and they cheapened it
what's worse when they realize their
mistake and they took away the financial
incentive the late pickup still stayed
at the high level
they had already poisoned the social
contract health care is full of strong
intrinsic motivations we have doctors
and patients who already want to do the
right thing financial incentives can
help but we shouldn't expect money in
health care to do all of the heavy
lifting instead perhaps the most
powerful influencers influencers of
health behavior are our social
interactions social engagement works in
health care and it works in two
directions first we fundamentally care
what others think of us and so one of
the most powerful ways to change our
behavior is to make our activities
witness Abul to others we behave
differently when we're being observed
than when we're not I've been to some
restaurants that don't have sinks in the
bathrooms instead when you step out the
sink is outside in the main part of the
restaurant where everyone can see
whether you wash your hands or not now I
don't know for sure but I am convinced
that hand-washing is much greater in
those particular settings we are always
on our best behavior when we're being
observed in fact there was this amazing
study that was done in an intensive care
unit in a Florida Hospital the
hand-washing rates were very low which
is dangerous of course because we can
spread infection and so some researchers
pasted a picture of someone's eyes over
the sink it wasn't a real person was
just a photograph in fact it wasn't even
their whole face it was just their eyes
looking at you hand-washing rates more
than doubled it seems we care so much
what other people think of us that our
behavior improves even if we merely
imagine that we're being observed and
not only do we care what others think of
us we fundamentally model our behaviors
on what we see other
people do and it all comes back to
seatbelts when I was a kid I used to
love the Batman TV series with Adam West
everything the Batman and Robin did was
so cool and of course the Batmobile was
the coolest thing of all now that show
aired from 1966 to 1968 and at that time
seatbelts were optional accessories and
cars but the producers of that show did
something really important when Batman
and Robin got in the Batmobile the
camera would focus on their laps and you
would see Batman and Robin put on their
seat belts now if Batman and Robin put
on their seat belts you can bet that I
was gonna wear my seat belt ooh I bet
that show saved thousands of lives and
again it works in health care too
doctors use antibiotics more
appropriately when they see how other
doctors use them so many activities in
healthcare are hidden their unwitnessed
but doctors are social animals and they
perform better when they see what other
doctors do so social influence works in
health care so does tying in to notions
of regret or to loss aversion we would
never think of using these tools if we
thought that everyone was rational all
the time now just to be clear I'm not
condemning rationality I mean that
really would be irrational but we all
know that it's the non-rational parts of
our minds where we get courage
creativity inspiration and everything
else that sparks passion and we know
something else too we know that we can
be much more effective at improving
health behavior if we work with the
irrational parts of our nature instead
of ignoring them or fighting against
them when it comes to health care
understanding our irrationality is just
another tool in our toolbox and
harnessing that irrationality that may
be the most rational move of all thank
you
[Applause]